[Music]  we're incredibly concerned by the huge  surge in the omicron variant over the  last 24 hours we've had the largest  number of new cases since this pandemic  began more than 26 000  [Music]  the impact of the last couple weeks has  been devastating  theaters bars  restaurants live music  they've seen bookings cancelled and  they've plummeted in relation to uh  bookings being cancelled the football to  the west end is down hugely so retail  will suffer and that's why we're calling  on the government it's crucial the  government's going to provide a  financial package of measures grants 100  business rates relief more news in  relation to furlough if the government  doesn't you're going to see many many  businesses going bust and tens of  thousands of people losing their jobs